بعد أيام من المفاوضات التي كانت تهدف
إلى تجنب استخدام الولايات المتحدة حق النقض (الفيتو) ضد قرار آخر للأمم المتحدة،
أصدر مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة قرارًا يسلط
الضوء على الحاجة الملحة لوصول
المساعدات الإنسانية إلى غزة،
ويدعو هذا القرار إلى وقف مؤقت
وممرات إنسانية عاجلة وممتدة
للسماح بدخول المساعدات
إلى غزة، قامت أيضًا بتعيين
منسق رسمي كبير للأمم المتحدة مسؤول عن
تسهيل وتنسيق دخول
المساعدات إلى غزة. لقد تعرضت إسرائيل بالطبع
لضغوط هائلة لزيادة
تدفق المساعدات إلى قطاع غزة،
وهذا فقط  منذ أسبوع ولأول مرة
قاموا الآن بفتح
معبر كاروم شالوم للسماح للشاحنات بالمرور
مباشرة من إسرائيل إلى قطاع غزة، وقد
قمنا بالفعل بزيارة ذلك المعبر يوم
الجمعة حيث رأينا عشرات الشاحنات
تشق طريقها عبر ذلك المعبر
ولكن أه يونايتد  ويقول مسؤولو الأمم المتحدة والمسؤولون الإنسانيون
إن هذا لا يزال غير
كاف لتلبية الاحتياجات الهائلة في غزة، حيث
يعاني حوالي نصف سكان غزة من
الجوع الشديد أو الشديد
وفقا لبرنامج الغذاء العالمي، لكن
إسرائيل تصر على وجود مسؤول كبير واحد على الأقل
مسؤول عن
منسق المساعدات العقيد موشيه تيترو
أصر لي على أنه لا يوجد
نقص في الغذاء وضغطت عليه بشأن هذه
القضية بالذات كما قلت لك هناك عشرات
الشاحنات المحملة بالأغذية تدخل إلى
قطاع غزة كل يوم هناك آلاف
الأطنان من الغذاء  تدخل قطاع غزة
كل يوم ولكن لماذا تقول أنه
لا يوجد نقص في الغذاء في غزة،
ألا يعني ذلك أنك
منفصل عن الواقع الذي
يعيشه الناس
هناك كما أخبرتك في الإحاطة التي
نقوم بها  تحليل يومي
للوضع مع
المنظمة الدولية ومع الأطراف الأخرى
والقطاعات الأخرى مثل
القطاع الخاص، وبينما تشير إسرائيل
بأصابع الاتهام إلى الأمم المتحدة ومنظمات الإغاثة
بسبب التدفق المحدود للمساعدات إلى
غزة الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
تشير إلى ذلك مباشرة قائلة
إن إسرائيل والطريقة التي
تدير بها هجومها هي التي
تخلق عقبات هائلة أمام
توزيع المساعدات في غزة، وفي الواقع
رأينا أدلة على تلك
العقبات نفسها بالضبط هذا الأسبوع فقط يوم
الخميس الذي تجري فيه إسرائيل عمليات
ضربة على الجانب الآخر من
معبر كوم شالوم، تلك الضربة أدت في الواقع إلى
مقتل المسؤول الفلسطيني
المسؤول عن ذلك الجانب من المعبر،
جيريمي دايموند سي إن إن تل أبيب